what is this white Fleck [ __ ] out here
uh-huh
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube whoo
oh man big news big news big news now I
have been gone from YouTube a lot longer
than I said I was going to pee
just to recap I said one month and that
[ __ ] turned into five I dealt with my
break like I deal with eating chocolate
chip cookies so how many cookies are you
gonna have one I swear to God
really just one one fourteen I don't
understand what why are we doing math
what's going on but all joking aside
there's a reason why I do the things
that I do so let me explain one of the
many things that I've been up to
now just as promised I did take a
one-month break from YouTube but after
that month I started to put in work
again it just didn't have to do with
YouTube yet but if you've been following
me in on Instagram aside from being busy
with like goop the film and promotion
and that and that had a great theater
run and on top of that I did mention
that I was working on a small project
with Kevin Hart's Network there was
something that I really really was
putting all of my effort heart and soul
into then I kind of dropped small hints
on but before I go ahead and talk more
about the brand and show you guys each
individual piece let me show you instead
of talking about it so this is the
official lookbook for a secret society
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can I get stuck on a [ __ ] real
quick stickin I don't give a [ __ ] what
you say you have never seen a fashion
lookbook on that caliber because that
wasn't just a lookbook my friends that
was a [ __ ] fashion film the
videographer that worked on this was a
really close friend of ours named Brian
dos Reis he is talented beyond means if
you want to give them a follow or if you
are even looking to go into videos or
video production look to this man
because he is somebody that's gonna
change this [ __ ] world one
secret society came about I think we
didn't want to create a brand that would
tell you who you are I think a lot of
the times when we wear clothing brands
or even when we create them we're so
helping and telling you how the clothes
defines you as a person when secret
society was being developed we had to
ask ourselves why is it that when you
wear clothes you have to belong to a
certain group or a specific lifestyle
and we started to realize at the end of
the day that brands tend to polarize you
secret society to us and for you guys
it's not that we are not creating a
brand to tell you what your lifestyle is
this brand is made to fit your lifestyle
in terms of fashion we're definitely
more minimalist when it comes to design
and color so we're not necessarily
trying to catch trends or waves
basically just to sum it up you want
people to be able to wear our clothes
for as long as possible based on our
design and quality rather than giving
people something that might be trending
for like a season or two so instead of
talking more about the Brent let me go
ahead and just show you the pieces that
we have this right here my friends is
the article one logo t this is why don't
white so it's a little bit hard to see
but let me just give you guys a quick
breakdown anyways so let's talk about
this but the article 1t it's made out of
100% cotton is made to fit over size and
it has a wide neck band which a lot of
us are used to there's an SS raised
rubber print logo in the center of the
chest and the really cool thing about
the shirts that I personally love aside
from the center logo is the fact that it
has an extended tail on the back side
slits and the secondary labels are on
the slits as well each t-shirt is
actually a cutting so piece made from
scratch to match our specific
measurements that we thought would be
the best Universal fit so once again if
you guys think that this is just some
blank that we put a logo on it's not
there's a lot more that went into
they're all cutting so and on top of
that that cotton is brushed and if
you've never had a brush cotton t-shirt
when you put this on your nipples will
say thank you
next up my friends is the article 1
numbers T this right here cousin this
right here my friend is my [ __ ] so this
shirt and compared to the shirt before
is going to be slightly oversized there
are unis leaves and a very thin neck
binding compared to the wide one that we
had before there's a numeric logo in
raised rubber print next to the bellow
chest pocket and of course just like the
other tee is all in the details there's
gonna be a raw edge sleeve and hem at
the end and also at the sleeves but once
again you have the secondary tag labels
on the side so just like the previous
t-shirt this is all cut and sew SPECT
out just a little differently so it has
more of a universal fit and of course it
also comes in white now I know I should
probably save the best for last but I
gotta talk about this piece because this
is actually something that I have on
rotation 24/7 and it's my favorite piece
of the collection this my friends is the
chico article 3 cropped trousers now I'm
not stunting or flexing on anybody but I
can't say this a hundred percent
honestly every time I wear these there's
always somebody asking me you know where
did you get those work and I copied and
that's the moment of pride for me
because they don't have to know who I am
and they already love the product now if
you don't know crop pants are something
that's huge out in Europe and Asia but
for some reason it's not big here yet
you know America has been a little bit
slower to adopt these but my thing is I
love them so why not be one of the first
to make this more prominent here and you
guys already know me if it's not
comfortable I'm not gonna rock it and I
can honestly say these are by far one of
the most comfortable pants I have ever
worn hands down and anybody who has put
their [ __ ] ass in this has said the
same so let's talk about the details so
when it comes to fitting these pants
obviously it's gonna be like t-shirts
you know small medium large exarch and
etc because it has a drawstring
waistband that's adjustable if it's
relaxed at the hips and if you're
wondering how it's gonna fit around the
legs it's gonna have a slightly tapered
opening on the front as well you are
going to see the bellowed front patch
pockets the secondary logos on the side
and when we flip it over to the back you
will see the embroidered secret society
logo and of course these hidden
pockets now if you're wondering what you
can wear these pants with I mean
obviously they're black pants you can
wear them with just about anything
these are my go to like I said before I
person elected wear these with my
enemies on my ultra boost just because
those things are clouds these pants
uncomfortable and if I wear them I'm
basically having a good [ __ ] day
so when it comes to comfort in style I'm
telling you you guys got to cop one of
these things this will be like the pants
that you'll have in rotation 24 [ __ ]
7 and everybody's gonna wonder where you
got this [ __ ] so let's talk about the
Article six embroidered anorak and this
is a piece that a lot of people have
been inquiring about now obviously I
don't have to say this but I'm going to
say it anyways because this is not your
typical hoodie so the fabric actually
doesn't have any stretch to it so it's
made a bit oversized and comfortable
enough so it could drape over your body
seamlessly but let's talk about the
details when it comes to this piece so
in the front you have an oversized
kangaroo pouch right here you have
stitching on the waistband as you can
see a trapunto stitch as they call it
like you guys really give a [ __ ] but and
then you have the secondary label here
on the front of the hoodie you had the
embroidered tonal SS number logo here
and then on the back you have the tonal
SS logo in the back and when we talk
about these pieces too it has to be
comfortable
this fits super comfortable and it's
going to make you feel good look good
it's my [ __ ] and trust me when you walk
down the street people be like where you
get that now the last piece that I'm
gonna get into before we go ahead and
talk about our accessories a secret
society is going to be our 3/4 sleeve
overcoat now typically with coasts what
you'll see is a three button closure but
instead we decide to do something a
little bit different so instead of the
classic three button to close the coat
we actually have an adjustable strap in
the front we have the bellowed front
patch pockets here and if we flip the
jacket to the back there's a vent for
added comfort when you walk because you
always think that with your coats and on
the sides we had the secondary labels
and of course we had the tonal
embroidered SS logo on the back of the
coat now something that I do want to
mention it when it comes to the coat
that I showed you the trousers and also
the hooded anorak is the fabric that is
made from in the engineering that went
behind it if you wanted me to break it
down a very specific mumbo-jumbo
basically it's like the transformer
cotton fiber that's into a shell fabric
by bonding at the poly
which is lightweight and very very
durable and by the way this is a fabric
that is typically being used in a lot of
high-end brands with coats that cost
literally up to five hundred to a
thousand dollars so last but not least
are the accessories and now it has
clearly their self-explanatory but I'm
just gonna give you guys a quick
breakdown here we have the secret
society beanies SS logo embroidered in
the front and the numeric logo right
here as well you have the SS level hat
which is the one that I'm wearing
I wear it everywhere it goes with
everything and the cool thing about the
hats that we have we actually had the
chapter two and three embroidered on the
the adjustable strap on the back I don't
think I actually explained this on the
video yet but the numbers for a secret
society basically stand for what secret
society is so it's 19 is s which is the
19th letter in the alphabet and of
course you can figure out the rest and
with these two hats right here you
actually can't cop it right now who
knows we might put it on the website if
you guys want it but this was a part of
a capsule collection that I did with a
Davis o comedy brand and secret society
so this is the Overlook Hat and mustard
and this right here is our state weird
cap in green and over here on the side
you'll see it labeled secret society the
date of the pop-up and it says somewhere
in k-town 2 1 3 which stands for la at
the pop-up as well we just didn't sell
the hats we also had a collaboration
piece with the Davis Okami brand and
secret society and basically the theme
of this was lost in translation so if
you look as this shirt right here it
says soul which is my last thing well
actually it saw but in English we write
so and soul means cow in Korean also
it's a hereditary name so lost in
translation that you see right there
absolutely love it and the back of the
t-shirt you have the label which has the
Davis old comedy stamp right there the
SS logo and chapter 2 and 3 collab size
on a large and the second shirt that we
had is the Homer tee and this is also
with the theme of lost in translation
because it says pill on the side
Homer is an alcoholic disease bottle you
know that these are the bottle double
entendre double meaning loss and
translation has home reporting a super
society in the middle and of course we
have the label on the neck right there
so yes everybody that
is secret society now on Instagram I
said I had a big announcement when it
came to this clothing and it wasn't just
to show you what the clothing is now
when I became a part of secret society I
actually came on the latter end and in
order for me to be evolved with this
brand and even though they're my friends
there was a stipulation that I told them
I had in order for me to be a part of
this company now secret society has
everything that I love and that I stand
for and if you want to learn more about
what secret society is and why we're
call secret society go to the website
check the About section and it's all
there when I think about of Brent it
does have to apply to me and one of the
things that I just had to change when I
became a part of secret society was the
pricing now mind you the pricing that
they had was very reflective of the
quality that you get in these clothes
and when you compared to other clothing
brands that are doing or trying to do
the same thing they're pricing there are
things at the price that is right now
two times over but even then I still had
to make it accessible to you guys now
watching this video you guys already
know the quality and time it takes to
create these products and you know and
even when it comes to our t-shirts
they're cut and sew and none of them are
done on blanks even then when it comes
to creating brand I always think about
you guys first and if I can get it in
your hands and at the pricing that is
set at right now
yeah it's fair but at the same time it's
not fair to you guys
so from starting today all the prices
have been adjusted and the point of this
was just to like show that in order for
a brand to live and especially if it
represents me it needs to get into the
hands of the people that I care about
the most
oh and I forgot to address this that
people have been asking about this [ __ ]
and I gotta tell you that this is so
like a mission with secret society it's
all about the details and this is one of
the things I'm super excited to share
with you guys is the peg that is even
packed in this is a secret society bag
that you're gonna get your clothing in
so you have the SS level in the front
and it's not just a typical clear
plastic bag where you just stamp your
logo on it obviously and of course we
have our secret society mantra be
numeric logo right there and telling you
guys that you guys are a part of our
family when you get your gear and lastly
aside from the clothes let's talk about
the things that you get
with it so every single piece that you
buy aside from the accessories like the
hats and stuff you are going to get
obviously the Hang pack which we did
work on which is very specific and this
piece right here you guys have been
asking on Instagram you know how can I
cop that piece how can I get the
necklace piece or the keychain it's not
a piece that you buy it actually comes
with every single article of clothing
that you buy aside from the accessories
so the reason why we had this piece is
basically it's kind of like your
induction into the secret society you
could wear this as a necklace you could
hang it on on your car you could have it
around your wrist and it's really up to
you on how you style it or how you wear
it but this is the piece that kind of in
ducks you into the secret society so
yeah my friends that is secret society
this is what I had been working on for
the past you know five months since I
had gone and it's a passion project but
on top of that too it's is fashion
that's successful with the quality that
you deserve and I hope you guys love it
let me know if you guys cop it and uh
thank you guys for watching man I can't
wait to see you guys rock our gear peace
you